あ
インフルの2社とは言いたいこんにちははじめシャツ方ですはい
だけで今回はですね
逗葉かな姉様って言われちゃ重要かもしれないんですけども重要じゃないって言ったら
強さはありません
まあ個人的なこっち側の動きの話なんですけどもお話させていただきます昔から僕の
動画を見てる人ならわかると思うんですけども僕動画の中で今の状況とか思ったことは
結構言っちゃうタイプなんですよ無理したくなくて目でしたくないんで例えば
大学が一緒だし買った時は大学が忙しい税
はいみたいなかなんか動画と動画の世界と現実の世界を割り切ることをせずなるべく
ありのままの自分で動画に入ってるつもりなのでちょっとそれを踏まえて今回のお話を
させていただきます
本当に個人的な話なんですけどもまぁタイトルにある通り
新メンバーが入ります早速は冷えといってもたぶんみなさんの想像しているような新
メンバーではありませんまぁ今までですねまあまあ先は結構出てくれてるんですけれど
も基本的には一人で僕のやりたいことを今までもこのチャンネルでやってきたので今後
それは多分ずっと変わらないと思います
わかんないけどねちょっとしたら変わるかもしれないけど基本的
には僕が一人動画に入ってて僕のしたいことを友達とか後輩とか他の湯チューバー
またきっと彼と楽しくやって食ってスタンスは変わらないんですけども今回増える新
メンバーっていうのはそういう動画に出てくる人が増えるというわけじゃなくて一緒に
動画を作っている
一緒に動画を作ってくれる人が一人増えるという2人
だったね1人増えるという意味でございますまあ要するに何だろうな
裏方さんです裏方さんが一人増えます
まぁちょっとその理由としてはいろいろと長くなるんですけどもみなさんご存知の通り
大学を卒業してからくらいかな
それまでも結構入ってたんですけども極端にやありがたいを話すんですけどありがとう
いくことに極端に東京に行くことがめちゃくちゃ
多くなりまして多いときだと週34号とかかな
ほぼ東京にいる時もあったりかといって東京に住みたくもないんですよねこの部屋も
いいしこの部屋を貸してくださっている大家さんもすごい理解があって
開かれちゃってくださいとか言ってくれ c やっぱ静岡に行ってくれる僕の友達とか
広範囲がねみんないい人なんです本当に何か道があった時もすぐ手伝ってくれたり僕も
したいですって言ってくれる仲間たちが多くてその他にいる奴らん
どんどん居心地がよくてかつ地味に年東京もそんな遠いわけじゃないので
今まで何度かやって来てくれてるんで
そういう意味もあってすごい静岡いいなと思ってまずと静岡にいるんですけども
基本的にはボカシ増加で楽しく動画を撮っているのが性にあってるんでそのスタンスは
今まで変わらないと思いますでですね
あの東京に行くことが極端に多くなってからですねメインチャンネルこの動画でこの
メインチャンネルの動画を作るため
に避けることのできる時間がかなり減ってしまいました
中には結構無理して動画を撮ったりおアーって焦りながら編集したりすることも結構
多くなっちゃって僕の中でばそれだとダメだなと思ってちょっとこれメディしてやっ
てるなんて思うことも何度かあったりしてちょっと僕の中でこれはなんとかしなきゃ
っていうのが今年の夏ぐらいですね
今年の夏
ぐらいにちょっと思ってたので弟をつけたりして色々調整したりしてやってたんです
けども
さすがにヤバいなと僕ですねでボクスターず的には1日1本作るのがすごい
あってるんですよ1日1本したいことを動画にして編集も全力でしてもう
俺は1本できた際なみたいなそのなんか楽しさがあってすごい
youtube 楽しくてやってて基本的に僕東京に行く時は何か用事があって東京に
いるんで東京だと動画の撮影ができない編集する時間もない朝から夜まで基本的には
全部何か入ってるんでまずしてその日の動画が撮れないんですよ
まあ本当に無理な時は休みますよ本当に無理な時は僕全然平気で
済んじゃうんですけど見てくださる方が多くて非常にありがたいのでできればねできれ
ば毎日動画を渡したいと思ってるんで東京にいるときは基本的にその前の日の静岡で
いる時に徹夜で編集して一本溝を作ってから
こんな川路東京に行くと言うなんて基本的に僕東京にいる時あの
の体調悪いです体な生活が続いておりましたことを知れば基本的にそんな感じでまえ
もって動画撮っとけよって言えばそれで終わりなんですけど
僕はやっぱね1日
1本作るのが楽しいです日本作ったら食べ2本目まずで面白くないから
や作ってる僕がね作っている僕が多分面白くないと思うんで楽しく生きたいわけなん
ですよ
楽しく泳げて結構その東京静岡の行き来が多すぎて洗濯を取り込む時間もない選択ホセ
ライダーに多分投票に行かなきゃいけなくて選択を干せないってタイミングが多かって
牧場
大僧都しないっていうのはあるんですけどもまぁ根本的に奏上する時間と金ゴミをし
てるよ1化も決まっているわけでなかなかゴミも捨てるってか今やすごいからねまあ見
ての通りちょっとね荒れに荒れてますここらへんも酷いねこれではひょっとしたら俺が
想像しないのはあるなおいで仮想ずしないのは多分
ちょびっとあると思うんですけどもうちょっと時間あったらひょっとしたら掃除するか
もしれ
ですね
っていう言い訳ですというですね僕の中で一番大処分しているメインチャンネルの
動画作りって時間が少ないのは本当によろしくないなと思ってまして実はちょいこの
メンバーを入れるっていうのを進めていまして
でまぁ全然将生とはポジションが違うんですけども新メンバーがやることは
えっと編集とか動画の編集とか撮影の手伝いカメラとか
何かモノを買ったり運んだりするどっちかというと僕のまわりのことを一緒にサポート
してくれるメンバーなので
動画に行ってません動画には出ないですねなんかね正木オカマ先にカメラまださせて
ますが最近
雅紀もバレちゃってるからそこでバレちゃってもうそもそも撮影にならないって
パターンが多くなってきたんで裏方さんみたいな人がちょっとこうも必要かなと思い
まして
高
海の決断に至りましたというわけでえっとそいつはですねは僕の友達なんですけどや力
はあるんですけど全然編集もしたことないし
youtube のことはあまり詳しくないので今後そういうことをいろいろ教えて
言ってですねまぁ最終的にどんどんできることを増やしていってあそうなることによっ
て僕の時間ができるわけです
今で編集したりね何かモノを買ったり運んだりいろんな作業を
を分担することによって僕の時間が結構できるのでメインチャンネルに僕が先は時間が
少しでも
増えてくれたらいいなと思っております
っていうお話なんで全然見てる皆さん僕の動画は多分まあ彼はないです
ひょっとしたら新メンバーの奴が編集してちょっといつもと違う完全になるかもしれ
ないんですけどそれも徐々に成長していくと思うので日本的にみてね皆さんに変化が
無いですあ僕の顔色がちょっと良くなるからいいかなっていう気がしますというお知ら
せでございます今年もうちょいあるんですけども
なかなかねメインチャンネルもっと頑張りたかったなぁって思う
ことが多い
1年でしたまだ終わってないけどねそろそろソロプレイも終わりです
だけじゃないんですよ一人でね youtube あるのって本当に結構大変でして
日か聞いたんでマジで凄いからね非課金者ますねすごいから web も本当すごいと
思います読むかずっとこの静岡東京を行き来している中でちょっと一人だと見解だなと
思って犬丸のことも main さん
で動画だすこともを持って行かないなと思ったので
共に面白いもの何か作ってくれる中の一人
入ることになりましたはいというお知らせでございますもう思ったこと全部言ったぞ
僕は今年ちょっとそういう感じでモヤモヤした1年だった今はそういう感じで私
そしてたまたまたまに正樹なんか下ネタみたいなとしてもう1人河田さらに
佐土新メンバーの3人体制でアプラス静岡の俺の友達と方ハイネのみんなで力を合わせ
て今後も楽しくっていこうと思います明日からその新体制で主導するので今後とも
はじめ冊をよろしくお願いします
ポケモン殿堂入りしましたじゃあな
me
いっ